>>> GO AWAY!
[ KNOCKING ]
>> HEY MAN.
SORRY TO BOTHER YOU.
WE'RE GO TO HEAD OVER TO THE
CHRISTMAS PARTY.
>> COOL, BYE.
>> I WAS JUST THINKING IF YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY PLANS, YOU ARE
MORE THAN WELCOME TO COME.
WE DON'T GET TO KICK IT THAT
MUCH ANYMORE.
IT COULD BE FUN.
YOU KNOW?
>> ALL RIGHT BUMBLE DOUG.
>> ARE YOU READY?
JUST A FEW MORE MINUTES.
I THINK MY ROOMMATE IS COMING.
>> WHAT?
SERIOUSLY YOU INVITED SCRUDGE.
>> COME ON.
IT'S CHRISTMAS.
THE GUY DOESN'T HAVE ANY FANS.
>> BECAUSE HE IS A NIGHTMARE.
>> WHAT UP, MAN, KEVIN?
STILL REALLY BORING?
COOL, LET'S GET FADED.
♪♪♪
>> WE BROUGHT GIFTS.
>> YOUR THINGS LOOK SO
INEXPENSIVE.
>> THANKS.
>> AND AN UGLY CHRISTMAS
SWEATER.
SO BRAVE OF YOU TO DO SOMETHING
SO PLAYED OUT.
OH, NO.
KATIE IS HERE.
WE HOOKED UP LIKE ONCE, AND NOW
SHE WON'T
STOP TEXTING ME.
IT'S LIKE, HEY.
HI.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M DOING, I SEE
YOU WATCHING MY INSTA STORIES.
ANOTHER REASON TO GET BLACK OUT.
>> TRY NOT TO BE A DICK TO
EVERYONE TONIGHT, PLEASE.
>> NOW BUMBLE DOUG.
>> HANNAH, DOPE DVD COLLECTION.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THERE ARE OTHER
WES ANDERSON FANS OUT THERE, LET
ME GUESS YOU LIKE THE SOUND
TRACK, TOO, BECAUSE YOU AND YOUR
FRIENDS SUCK.
>> COME ON.
>> DVDs ARE TIGHT.
IT'S NOT LIKE YOU CAN STREAM
EVERY MOVIE EVER MADE.
MIND IF I SNEAK A TEENY TINY.
BUM.
>> WE DON'T HAVE MUCH LEFT.
HEY, DUDE, CAN I GET THAT BAG
BACK.
>> DUDE, WHAT?
I GAVE IT BACK TO YOU.
>> NO, YOU DIDN'T.
>> YEAH, DUDE I LITERALLY JUST
GAVE IT BACK TO YOU.
ARE YOU LIKE HIGH, DUDE?
>> WHAT?
>> HEY, CAN I BUM A CIGARETTE?
>> I ONLY GOT ONE LEFT?
THAT'S ALL I NEED.
>> SCRUDGE, KIND OF AN ASSHOLE.
>> WHOA, EVERYBODY HAS BEEN
DYING TO KNOW WHAT THE SAD,
LONELY ROOF GUY THINGS, AND I
GET TO KNOW IT FIRST, # WINNING
HASHTAG TIGER BLOOD.
[ BLEEP ] YOU, LOSER.
>> TAKE A LOOK DOWNSTAIRS.
YOU MIGHT NOT BE AS COOL AS YOU
THINK.
>> I'M SCRUDGE.
I MAKE EVERYONE FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> IS HE LIKE A THOUSAND YEARS
OLD.
>> DOES HE OWN A
TOOTHBRUSH?
>> HE'S JUST MY ROOMMATE.
HE'S NOT REALLY MY FRIEND.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH LONGER I
WANT TO LIVE WITH HIM.
>> MICHAEL?
>> NOT TOO LATE, SCRUDGE.
♪ WHAT HAVE I BEEN ♪♪♪
>> EVERYBODY, PLEASE LISTEN.
I HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY.
I'M SORRY.
I HAVE BEEN AWFUL TO EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF YOU.
BUT TONIGHT, THANKS TO YOU, I
HAVE REALIZED THAT THE TRUE
MEANING OF CHRISTMAS IS TO SPEND
TIME WITH THOSE YOU LOVE, WHICH
IS WHY I SHOULDN'T BE HERE.
I'M SORRY.
TRULY, REALLY SORRY, EVERYONE.
EAT MY BUTT.
[ APPLAUSE ]